In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading, from the Sinaxadion for June 3rd, on which we commemorate St. Clotilde,
Queen of the Franks.
St. Clotilde was the daughter of Shilperic, who shared with his two brothers the Kingdom
of Burgundy, which stretched from the Jura to the Durants.
She was born in about 475, at the time when, after the collapse of the Roman Empire, the
barbarian peoples, Burgundians, Visigoths, Franks, and Elements were rivaling one another
in dividing Gaul among themselves.
Orthodox through her mother, although all the other Burgundian sovereigns had been won over
to Aryanism, she had to go into exile after the assassination of her parents by her uncle
and lived a devout life in Geneva.
The young and beautiful princes having been noticed by the ambassadors of Clovis, King
of the Franks, he asked for her hand in marriage, in order to seal the alliance between his people
and the Burgundians, circa 492.
By her gentleness and the example of her virtuous life, the Queen acquired great influence
over Clovis.
He agreed to have their sick child baptized, and it recovered through its mother's prayers.
But as for him, Clovis continued death to his wife's exhortations until the day when,
having to confront the Elements at Tolbjak across the Rhine in 496 and terrified by the superiority
of his adversary, he called on the God of Clotilda, and promised him that he would be baptized
if he gave him victory.
The Franks, having triumphed, the King kept his promise, and, after having followed the
catechetical teaching given by Saint Vost, he was baptized by Saint Remi, Bishop of Rings,
on Christmas Day in 496.
This baptism of Clovis, and with him more than 3,000 Frankish nobles and soldiers, opened
the way to the conversion of his people destined to become a Christian nation full of promise.
From this time, Queen Clotilda continued to inspire the sovereign with forbearance towards
his enemies, and a respect for the institutions of the Church.
In Paris, their capital, she had a Basilica built, dedicated to the Holy Apostles, now Saint
Genevieve, in which the remains of Saint Genevieve, whom Clotilda venerated with great fervor,
were buried.
On the death of Clovis, the Queen, barely forty years old, with drew to tours close to
the Basilica of Saint Martin, whose veneration she also encouraged, and she spent the rest
of her days in God-pleasing works of devotion.
Disposing of an immense fortune, she spread her benefactions over the great many churches and
monasteries, Saint Gregory of Tours wrote about her. She was considered in these times not as a queen,
but as a personal servant of God. She did not let herself be seduced by the power of the kingdoms
of her sons, nor by riches, nor by the ambition of the times, but she achieved grace through humility.
It is said that she gave away so much that on her death she had nothing left.
Crowley struck by the death of her eldest son, Clotilda, and the war with the Burgundians,
she gathered her three young children together in tours. When her two other sons, Clotér
and Chilbert, asked her to send the orphans to them in Paris, to be brought up at court,
she submitted without suspicion, but learned shortly afterwards with horror that they had been
cruelly assassinated by their uncles, and only one of them, Claude of Ald, had succeeded in
escaping to a monastery. At the same time she also lost her daughter, who had been given in
marriage to the cruel and violent Amaleric King of the Visigoths, deprived from then on of all
earthly consolation, Clotilda devoted the whole of her life to the veneration of Saint Martin.
When her two sons went to war against each other in 534, she threw herself on a saint's tomb
to implore his intercession, and a tempest miraculously arose to separate the two armies and
urge the two brothers to reconciliation. Sensing her approaching end, some in Clotér and Chilbert
to her side, and exhorted them to live their lives in Christian charity, then having foretold them,
events that were to come she peacefully gave her soul into God's keeping on the third of June,
in 545, confessing the Holy Trinity. The model of a Christian widow and sovereign,
Saint Clotilda, has been venerated as the founders and protectors of the French monarchy.
According to one legend, she, at the revelation of an angel, armed Clovis for battle,
with a shield decorated with three Fleur de Lise, a symbol of the Holy Trinity, which became the
emblem of the kings of France. Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God,
have mercy on us and save us.